you guys are actually going to get the  ultimate hall pass to explore what life  would be like with someone other than  your spouse I am doing my breathing guys  your marriage perhaps doesn't have maybe  that fire that it used to have that  Fuego that passion you know  [Music]  we could have some fun yeah  well here they come  this experience I'm hoping will give a  spark back to my husband  is  I think living with these guys is gonna  be a fun experience something will most  likely happen just a matter of time how  do you think your wife would feel about  this oh my God she's 23.  it is now your Moment of Truth do you in  fact have a love for the ages or will  you decide to walk away